je sais que c'est très attendu vous pour
vous et la russie oui parce que
jusqu'ici un des arguments que vous
pouvez utiliser contre eric zemmour
c'est qu'il ne sortait pas du cadre des
plateaux télé des meetings politiques
pour affirmer ses idées qui sont très
durs envers de certaines parties de la
population là il a joué le rôle le jeu à
100% il s'est retrouvé face aux gens il
y avait des témoins comme ceux ci qui
était prévu mais aussi des gens qui
l'ont interpellé directement dans la rue
il y aller est ce que j'ai apprécié
c'est que son discours n'a pas changé
quand il s'agissait de dire les choses
en face aux gens donc c'était très
courageux de sa part c'est vrai ça que
je savais à quoi je m y avait à peu près
dix neuf gardes du corps quand même
toute une équipe derrière il n'a pas été
pas vrai n'importe qui c'est normal non
mais pas griser par je ne parle pas de
quoi j'avais aurait pu
et
on laisse tomber dans ce que voulez vous
les éviter on me demande alors battu
alizé combien ce que je voulais
justement éviter c'était le spectacle et
la sai et zemmour c'est maintenant le
one man show les idées on les connaît
lady partout et maintenant et monte sur
scène donc là ça y est on y est c'est du
one man c'est le trump à amor est
maintenant vraiment c'est tout ce que
j'ai testé la politique spectacle et
quand on est nécessaire et la politique
bah c'est pas de se balader avec seize
gardes du corps pour aller voir
quelqu'un et puis en mairie midi ils
étaient obligés
vous répondez pas la question a choisi
il prouve que justement il a réussi
exactement pancartes match va examiner
ça dit non d'un point de vue idéologique
oui je suis d'accord avec toi mais il a
réussi parce que d'abord il a fait un
point lannoy que c'est pas un petit mec
du 16e rallye - combien de 500 me contre
moi mais on le savait ça qu'il est nos
banlieues nommé souffler avoir tout d'un
coup tu vomis les des cités où il y ait
débat ils n'arrêtent pas de stigmatiser
cette année avec 50 gardes du corps de
quoi tu parles géraldine mais mais mais
mais mathieu sinon papa quand l'émission
et je suis d'accord oui mesdames ultime
défi voile non mais l'après-midi alors
on défend des noms mais juste l'image
est forte après oui pour moi il a fait
un gros coup
pour moi il après coup je vous dis les
hôtes aurait dû le faire et là il a fait
un gros coup je vous dis à venir il a
été malin franchement il a été malin
parce que et et c'est vrai que voilà ça
ne s'arrange pas mérité malin
oui donc il vient de drancy ok peut-être
que toi tu le sais mais on ne le sait
pas voilà une adresse ci est grâce à
l'école de la république il est sorti de
scène de son extraction sociale il est
devenu un grand jour les deux ans déjà
il montre ça et ensuite deuxièmement
enfin moi je trouve qu'il est quand même
très très habile parce que je trouve
qu'ils montrent encore une fois que
c'est le maître des horloges de dire
qu'ils montrent que c'est lui qui décide
de ce qui le canal de quand il veut en
fait le producteur de la campagne mais
toi long du court après on est tous des
toutous derrière lui et on lui couvre
près de la haye la raison d'un point de
vue comme moi je suis pas daccord
évidemment sur ce qu'il dit et sur les
solutions parce que c'est ya qu un
faucon et en fait c'est complètement
bidon n'y a pas de solution et d'un
point de vue de qom c'est juste parfait